or just trying to build little bits of
the puzzle what do you remember about
the incident I like this one look at the
map where were you when it happened I
don't remember when you came around
did you see people yes
what were they doing
they were dead we are an awful I like
you I'll be pause went through the
sooner we get back to a normal routine
the better
[Music]
oh but that Blackwell said he sent me
exactly where I needed to be into who I
needed to be with is your mother dead
too
yes
I know you were there and I know what
else was in that room
the goldfish before and after everything
is before and after in the middle is the
painting
past life
he's alone miracle after miracle it
survives there's something important
I've to tell you
until you is it lost
[Music]
even the tiniest things means something
[Applause]
who took the pain
well good forever
[Music]
maybe some high school to them can come
from dead
[Music]
who's my thought she died
I would have given it back I swear
[Music]
[Music]
you